it's gabrielle union
hi hi how is
everyone how are you drew oh gabrielle i
feel like i'm getting to know you
so well through reading your book i oh
you're learning
way too much oh by the way
i was watching all the press for
bringing on 20th anniversary
and is it true it's true
oh my god i mean
i can't even tell you all day long
me and my girls sing the torah's like
song
i i i just i'm so excited
my my daughters are going to freak out
that i was with you today and all night
long we're going to be
burr it's cold in here
there must be some torahs in the
atmosphere
i said oh yo yo ice ice
ice oh my god it's so good sorry i had
to
sorry it's okay it's okay you're not
alone
okay i'm sure you must get that oh
all the time all the time and i don't
remember the cheer so that's like
thank you there's um you know a video
that went viral
of you and kavya she's upset
about um a bag um
and she started kicking it sometimes i
literally think like my kids are the
only one who are behaving
this way and it does make you feel like
you're alone in ireland so
there's not a hallmark greeting card for
relief and there should be
because i think we all feel relieved
when we see other parents going through
the same thing
yes like you know like i i started the
the motherhood journey a little
a little later and a little later in the
game i'm a little longer than in the
tooth than i had imagined you know when
i was
uh you know coming up um i assumed you
know i would you know be a young mom
um not a mom with lower back pain and
and you know
um who like to listen to their you know
earth wind and fire
um so it's a little different but it's
every day is like a new surprise
like watching her with that backpack you
know so all of us
my little sister uh moved uh you know
during covid to help us with with cobb
um and we have like this huge village
but we're just watching her
and we're like where is she getting this
from we're all relatively peaceful zen
masters at the in this house so watching
her
the rage like we call it the ragi rage
like where did that even come from
that's just
you know that just came from inside of
this little this little person
oh i'm reading your book right now and
you had fire in you when you were young
and like i you know i think you're
probably zen
now because you took a whole lifetime to
get there
i love also your romantic beautiful love
story with
dwayne listen relationship goals it's
you know we it we all need it how is it
parenting with him
you know with each kid it's a little
different like we definitely
had to get out of the one-size-fits-all
parenting rather quickly
so i'm a stepmom to you know uh four
kids
and uh and then we share cov together
and my husband started his parenting
journey
you know pretty young and so i think
over time
and then since we've been married we've
together have come into a different
parenting style
so with cobb we're very much on the same
page um same with xayah
but like with the the 18 year olds i
am like this psychotic overbearing
um what are you doing now kind of parent
and my husband's like whatever um
you know they're they're gonna figure it
out and i'm like but we can help them
figure it out
if we just hover over them um
so i i'm learning to kind of let go
they're both away at school and it's
really really hard for me i probably
talked to them more now
that they're gone out of the house than
when they were you know we were all
under the same roof i'm
it's it's terrifying for uh you know for
me
um having them be across the country by
themselves on these new journeys and
we're not right there and it's it's
driving me crazy and then the girl
situation i
i i become somebody that i hated dealing
with uh
you know when i was dating as a teen oh
i look forward to my daughter's date
showing up where i have like
you know a thought-off weapon an nda
a chastity belt and a taser so i hear
you
um one thing i have to mention is i
cannot stop eating these
these are bitsies your amazing new snack
and by the way very important they are
school
safe which i really want to press upon
because that's such
a concern of a lot of parents they are
so delicious and amazing i've googled
you can find them at amazon and whole
foods and
any other vendors we'll put it on the
website parents you're not going to
believe
how incredible these are and we have
more to talk about with gabrielle
that she is contributing and producing
and putting out into the world
product wise she's making the world a
more delicious
and beautiful place
you